- [Interviewer] How'd
you get the name Butter?
- That is my nickname, like from family.
- [Interviewer] Since a kid or
since you work in the street?
- Since I was a kid, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Alright
Butter, where are you from?
Where did you grow up?
- [Butter] I grew up in Carson, California
and then as I grew older I
moved to (mumbles) California.
- [Interviewer] And tell me
about your family growing up.
You had both your parents?
- Yeah I was with my mom growing up,
my mom and my dad separated
but, you know, my mom was a good mom.
She did everything she could.
She was a stripper for 20 years, so...
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
Any abuse, any traumatic
events that had happened?
- No child abuse.
At the end of the day when
my grandma and grandpa died,
that's when life really
got hard for my momma
because she was adopted and stuff
so at the end of the day
that's the most traumatic
thing that happened,
when my grandparents died.
- [Interviewer] And how
far did you go in school?
- I made it to the 11th grade,
well I made it to the 12th
but I end up going to jail
and I never completed it.
- [Interviewer] And you
start working the street
at what age?
- At 15.
- [Interviewer] 15.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How'd you do that?
Did you meet somebody?
- Yeah I met some guy
and basically he was
just taking care of me,
like what I thought he
was taking care of me,
like grooming me and he take
me to the nail shop at 70,
he took me to a place and he was like,
"You need to get out and make some money
to prove that you care for me."
And that's where it all went down.
- [Interviewer] So he was
operating basically as a pimp?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Or a boyfriend hustler?
- Well, he was my boyfriend I thought,
he was my nigga because I was 15,
not even about to be 16.
So, I was just experiencing guys, so yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
remember your very first time
picking up a trick?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Do you
remember your very first time
picking up a John?
- Yeah, well that was
when I was down for him.
- [Interviewer] Who was
your first customer?
- I went to jail my first time.
- [Interviewer] You did?
- Yeah. Dead ass serious.
- [Interviewer] It was a cop?
- Yeah, it was undercover.
- [Interviewer] Oh, wow.
- (mumbles)
- [Interviewer] And are
drugs a part of your life?
- Yeah, weed.
- [Interviewer] Nothing else?
- I used to do cocaine.
- No
- [Interviewer] You sure?
- I'm positive.
- [Interviewer] And today
you're working on your own
or with a...
- Today I'm working on my own.
- [Interviewer] You are?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how is that?
- It's okay working on your own
cause at the end of the day
you can see more of your money
and you could benefit off of it more
if you just do the right thing.
But right now for me,
it's been hard because
I just left a situation
with a pimp.
So, I'm just starting over.
- [Interviewer] Right.
What are the advantages
or disadvantages of both?
- The advantages are the pimp
is always going to be on call
when you need him,
he's going to take you to the money.
And the disadvantages is
nothing that you have,
or you worked for,
or you sold your pussy for,
or you sucked dick for is yours.
You don't get to keep none of it.
When you leave, you
gonna leave with a jacket
and maybe the shoes on your feet,
and if you get lucky the
wig on your head, so...
That's the advantages and disadvantages.
- [Interviewer] And doing it on your own,
you get to keep your money?
- You do get to keep your own money
but at the end of the day I
have reckless spending problems,
I don't know how to manage my money,
so I could owned a house already.
But I'm trying to live like I'm rich.
- [Interviewer] And do
you have a boyfriend now?
- No, I don't.
- [Interviewer] It's hard
to have a boyfriend doing
this kind of work, right?
- Yeah, someone who takes me serious.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Very few guys will put up
with a girl that's doing
this kind of work, right?
- You right, I've only had
one serious relationship.
- [Interviewer] And how'd that go?
- It went good, you
know, it ran it's course,
and it's actually my baby's father, so...
He's in jail.
- [Interviewer] He's in jail?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you have kids?
- Yeah, I have one child.
- [Interviewer] And are
you raising him or her?
- Yeah, I'm raising her,
along with my family.
- [Interviewer] What
emotions does this lifestyle
bring out for you?
- For me it makes me lonely,
and it just makes me kind of,
not I don't want to say heartless,
cause I wear my feelings on my sleeve,
but it makes me just not pay attention,
it makes me aware,
makes me feel like this shit is okay,
and I know it's really not.
- [Interviewer] So deep down
you know that this is probably
not the best lifestyle for you?
But there's no other options for you,
is that what you feel?
- I feel like this is the
best thing I'm good at.
- [Interviewer] You have
bad experiences out there,
doing it?
- Yeah, I've had quite a few.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of stuff has happened?
- Well, I've never got raped before,
by a guy, like a trick or anything,
a John or whatever you call him.
But, at the end of the day
I've got robbed at gunpoint,
while doing the job.
Or I've had guys,
you date black guys but
you're not supposed to,
and then they give you the money,
the $150 or $200 and then
if one thing don't go right
they want to take your money.
And it's like, what I worked for,
for one I worked for it,
and then for two now I done told this pimp
that I'm paying that I
got this amount of money
and now I don't have
nothing to show for it
in the amount of time
that I was with the John.
So, it's like, that's a bad experience.
- [Interviewer] So, the pimps you've had
have advised you not
to go with black guys?
- Not all of them,
but, most of them have, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What's the hardest part about
doing this kind of work?
- Being away from my baby.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What mistakes have you
learned from in doing this?
Are there things you've learned that like
I wished I knew that earlier on?
- I'm still learning,
but at the end of the day I
just wish I learned sooner,
basically just not to trust people.
And I already knew that,
but I was seeing stuff
before it even happened,
and I be in a situation that
I didn't want to be in, so...
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- 27.
- [Interviewer] 27?
What was the best time of your life?
- The best time in my
life was November 19th,
when I had my baby.
- [Interviewer] That's
always, every mother's
answer is the same.
- I was supposed to have
my daughter on my
birthday on December 19th,
but I had her a month
early on November 19th.
And she was still healthy and everything.
So, it's a blessing.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that
do this kind of work?
Or about you, what is it about you?
- [Butter] The most misunderstood
thing about me is that
people just think that
I think I'm all that
and they think that,
I don't know, the most
misunderstood thing is,
I don't know, I guess I don't
try to portray to be perfect,
but I just love myself,
and I take myself into consideration,
and people be hating me,
and they don't be liking me or treating me
how I treat them.
Cause I give to a lot of people,
but people always be trying to step on me
or they think I'm weak or something.
- [Interviewer] You
understand that 99% of hate
is just envy?
- [Butter] Yeah, but it can break you.
- [Interviewer] We talked
about that before we started.
Now what's been the
worst time in your life?
- [Butter] The worst
time in my life was when
my baby daddy when to
jail in July of 2016.
One day the Feds came
and knocked on the door
and ransacked the house and everything,
and all that.
And my baby was three
years old at the time.
So I became a single
mother in that instant.
- [Interviewer] How do you
think working this kind of life,
doing this kind of work has changed you?
- [Butter] It's made me very blunt
and sometime I don't
take people's feelings
into consideration.
And I be self centered.
- [Interviewer] You can see
that this life is crazy, right?
It's a very dangerous life
style for a girl, right?
- Exactly. It is, and I'm not
just saying that to agree,
yes, it is, cause I'm living it.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
it builds your self esteem,
or undermines it, or does both?
- It just depends on who
you surround yourself with.
If you weak and you surround
yourself around a pimp
or something that's going to pull you down
and tear you down,
that's what it's going to be,
but, I don't know,
it's hard to answer.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, do
you still believe in love?
- No, uh-huh.
I know I be falling in love fast,
but it's lust, it's not love.
I don't believe in love. Period.
- [Interviewer] What kinds
of things does a girl need
to know before she gets
into this kind of life?
What would you advise a
young girl who's thinking
about it?
- Just, don't pay no guy
if you want to get into it,
or whatever, if you want to get into it,
don't get into it.
I don't even promote it.
To dead ass serious,
it's different strokes
for different folks.
Me, I'm just a regular,
I'm a woman, but I'm
trying to get some money,
and I've been, know how to do it,
so, at the end of the
day money attracts to me,
so I don't know.
But, it's different strokes
for different folks.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think you're addicted to it?
- Yeah, probably, because I be like,
if I'm bored, I'm like,
I'm about to go (mumbles)
And like who just goes
to hang out on the blade,
but I'm not hanging out,
like I be (mumbles)
I want some money.
At least it's thirsty like,
but it ain't thirsty,
I'm thirsty for money.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it
makes it hard to get out.
- Yes, I see myself as
being not a millionaire,
or you know, the thing
that's under a millionaire,
I see myself having a lot of things,
and I have had things, so...
I don't know, I want to
have better for myself
and for my daughter.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
do you get risky things
that the John's want to do with you?
- All the time, with no condoms, and,
I'm not doing that,
but it's fetishes and all that.
And, I could be doing that shit, but no.
I'm not sucking dick with no condom,
risking, you could get herpes on your lip
from sucking dick, putting a condom on it
with your mouth tryin' to be cute.
So, excuse me.
- [Interviewer] And what's
the most important lesson
you've learned?
- Just be aware of the
guy that you're dating.
And like, you don't need to
have no home girls in the game.
Cause these bitches ain't
your friends, basically.
- [Interviewer] All right
Butter, well thank you
so much for sharing your story.
And I wish you the best of luck,
hope you get to spend as much time
as you need to with your daughter.
- [Butter] Okay, and I appreciate you
for even taking your time out your day
to interview me, and talk to me.
- [Interviewer] Oh, thank you.
I love hearing your stories.
- [Butter] I hope it's genuine,
cause I got enough going on.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, no, it's always nice
when someone's honest, and open, and...
- [Butter] Yeah, and I
really was, for real.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
awesome, thank you, darling.
- [Butter] Thank you.